This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是人类制作。百分之二。这就是有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧意志、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。也就是数字 2. percent，在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像马尔科姆·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代一样。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.
在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast whereby we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Okay, this week we're talking about narcissism and the narcissist. You know, what better week to kind of talk about this? my ex-boyfriend popped up to me in case anyone was interested. So I was like, wow, that kind of reminds me of a topic I haven't covered yet. What better way to kind of take some inspiration from my own life?
在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 learn the hard way。你好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时的一些重大变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。好的，本周我们来聊聊自恋和自恋者。你知道，还有什么比这周更适合聊聊这个话题的呢？我的前男友突然来找我了，以防有人感兴趣。所以我当时想，哇，这让我想起了一个我还没涉及的话题。还有什么比从我自己的生活中汲取灵感更好的方式呢？
Let him know I'm still thinking about him. No, all jokes aside. I have really wanted to cover this for a while. I think it's a really interesting personality disorder. And a lot of the time on this show, we don't really discuss, I think, clinical disorders or pathological disorders it's more like a broader discussion of things with I think some tenuous links to psychology and kind of jumping into it but I really wanted to discuss the psychology of narcissism because I think that it's become a term used very frequently it's one of
让他知道我还在想他。不，不开玩笑了。其实我一直很想聊聊这个。我觉得这是一种非常有趣的性格障碍。而且在这个节目中很多时候，我们其实并不讨论，我觉得是临床障碍或病理障碍，它更像是一个更广泛的话题讨论，我认为与心理学有一些微弱的联系并深入探讨，但我真的很想讨论自恋的心理学，因为我认为它已经成了一个使用非常频繁的术语，它是
those crossovers between pop culture and psychology that's we're seeing like a lot more of these days another example is like gas sliding people use that all the time or so saying that someone is a narcissist is obviously a pretty, a pretty big one. But I do think we all know someone who's a narcissist. Just take a moment. Think about the people in your life. Maybe self-diagnose them. Maybe you've even had thoughts that you are a narcissist. And if you have, no fear, because that probably means that you're not, which we're going to discuss in this episode. I think in your 20s you are very likely to encounter kind of a new breed of person as our identities become more developed. Someone whose ego just seems a little bit too big for their boots to hold.
流行文化和心理学之间的交叉点之一，我们现在看到这类情况越来越多了。另一个例子就像是煤气灯操纵（gaslighting），人们经常使用这个词。所以说某人是自恋者，显然也是一个相当、相当重大的指控。但我确实认为我们都认识自恋者。花点时间想一想。想想你生活中的人。也许可以给他们自我诊断。也许你甚至有过自己是自恋者的想法。如果你有，不用害怕，因为这可能意味着你不是，我们将在本节中讨论这一点。我认为在二十岁时，随着我们的身份变得更加成熟，你很有可能会遇到一种新品种的人。那种自我膨胀到让人觉得有点承受不起的人。
So if these people exist and we're likely to encounter them and, you know, in our 20s is probably the first time we really meet someone that's like this and we're able to see that that's abnormal, how do we have relationships with these people? How do we interact with them? How do we work with them? how do we date them? I also really wanted to explore some of the misconceptions around narcissism. Like I said, it is such a popularized term, but how often do we just use it quite flippantly without really knowing what it actually means and whether someone actually is a narcissist, whether we can call them that? So we're going to discuss also some of the clinical implications of narcissism. So where does it come from? This discussion that it's in every corner of psychology
所以，如果这些人存在，而我们很有可能会遇到他们，而且，你知道，在我们二十岁时，可能也是我们第一次真正遇到这样的人，并且能够看出这并不正常，我们如何与这些人建立关系？我们如何与他们互动？我们如何与他们共事？我们如何与他们约会？我还真的很想探讨一些围绕自恋的误解。正如我所说，这是一个非常大众化的术语，但我们多久才会相当轻率地使用它，却没有真正理解它实际上意味着什么，以及某人是否真的是自恋者，我们是否可以这样称呼他们？所以我们还将讨论自恋的一些临床影响。那么它来自哪里呢？这种无处不在的心理学讨论
is narcissism, nature or nurture? Yeah, that's a huge debate that's been raised for a long time. And I don't think psychology is coming any closer to finding a real answer for that. Another big question is, you know, does narcissism have a cure? And should we deal with it? Whoa. There we go. Brief intermission.
自恋是天生还是后天？是的，这是一个长期存在的巨大争论。我不认为心理学更接近于找到这个问题的真实答案。另一个重大问题是，你知道，自恋能治愈吗？我们应该处理它吗？哇。好了。短暂的中场休息。
Bless me. Anyhow, does narcissism have a cure? And should we deal with it as a mental disorder, perhaps a condition, rather than just seeing it as maybe a fault of someone's character. Yeah, just some really big questions, but I think on a more personal note, we're going to discuss narcissism in our own lives, what it means for someone to be a narcissist,
保佑我。不管怎样，自恋能治愈吗？我们是否应该将其作为一种心理障碍，也许是一种状况来处理，而不仅仅把它看作是某人性格上的缺陷。是的，只是一些非常大的问题，但我认为从更个人的角度来看，我们将在我们自己的生活中讨论自恋，对某人来说成为自恋者意味着什么，
how they operate their behaviours, what it's like to date someone who's a narcissist, what it's like to be around people who are narcissists, and how to kind of escape the manipulation and the charisma of a narcissist. And don't worry, I do get the irony. I think it's kind of funny, like, here I am. you know, making my own podcast, like listening to the sound of my voice and the episode is on narcissism. But maybe I'll, I don't know, I don't think I'm a narcissist, but maybe someone will
他们如何运作他们的行为，与自恋者约会是什么感觉，和自恋者在一起是什么感觉，以及如何摆脱自恋者的操纵和个人魅力。别担心，我知道这其中的讽刺意味。我觉得这挺搞笑的，就像，我在这里。你知道，制作我自己的播客，就像听着我自己的声音，而这一集的主题却是自恋。但也许我会，我不知道，我不认为我是个自恋者，但也许有人会
think I am after listening to some of these criteria. So buckle in because I've got a lot of energy today. Like I said, it's been a very complicated week. And this is a topic I really want to dig into, so let's do it. So narcissism is extreme self-involvement to the degree that it makes a person ignore the needs of those around them. So while everyone, you know, may show occasional narcissistic behaviour, because as my good friend Kate says, everyone is, you know, the centre of their own universe. So it makes sense that sometimes you have self-involvement. But true narcissists, they will frequently discard others' feelings and don't even seem to be aware of them. So they also just do not understand the effect that their behaviour has on other people so they're unable to comprehend
在听了其中一些标准后认为我是。所以系好安全带，因为我今天精力充沛。就像我说的，这是一个非常复杂的星期。这也是一个我真的很想深入探讨的话题，所以我们开始吧。自恋是极端的自我卷入，达到了让一个人忽视周围人需求的程度。因此，虽然每个人，你知道，都可能表现出偶尔的自恋行为，因为正如我的好朋友凯特所说，每个人，你知道，都是他们自己宇宙的中心。所以有时候你会表现出自我卷入是合情合理的。但真正的自恋者，他们会经常无视别人的感受，甚至似乎根本意识不到这些感受。因此，他们也不理解自己的行为对其他人产生的影响，所以他们无法理解
how their own self-involved behaviours have first and second order consequences. There are no like physical blood tests, MRIs, GP appointments or, you know, exact biological determinations that can identify a narcissist. Even therapists do just have to go on observations of the behavior and the attitude that a person presents. There's no like quiz. Like, you might see people like posting things or like BuzzFeed quizzes are like, are you a narcissist, but that's not how it works. They basically have to just base what they're seeing in a person off of the DSM criteria. And some of these criteria include superiority and entitlement, which we've talked about. So someone feeling like they deserve anything they would like and just go to any
他们这种自我卷入的行为所产生的一阶和二阶后果。没有什么物理血液检测、核磁共振、全科医生预约，或者，你知道，确切的生物学测定可以识别出自恋者。甚至治疗师也只能根据一个人表现出的行为和态度来进行观察。没有什么像测试的东西。就像，你可能会看到人们发布一些东西，或者像BuzzFeed的测试问卷问：你是自恋者吗？但事情不是这样的。他们基本上只能根据在一个人身上看到的情况，对照精神障碍诊断与统计手册（DSM）的标准来进行判断。其中一些标准包括我们已经讨论过的优越感和特权意识。也就是说，某人觉得自己理应得到他们想要的任何东西，并且不择
means to obtain that regardless of who they step on. For a narcissist, like, there is no such thing as being wrong or feeling inferior. This also kind of goes along with an exaggerated need for attention and validation, as well as, like, this need to control their relationships, as well as their work and their own lives. And I think the three biggest indicators, though, that are, like, firstly, you know, massive red flags in any relationship, but also cause a lot of interpersonal conflict and difficulty. And then these are these three huge red flags related to narcissism and how it presents in people. These are a lack of boundaries, a lack of responsibility for their own actions. So someone who is a narcissist, they always blame outside events or people or emotions for
手段去获取，而不管他们踩在谁的头上。对于自恋者来说，没有“错误”或“感到自卑”这回事。这通常也伴随着对关注和认可的夸大需求，以及控制他们的关系、工作和自己生活的需要。而我认为最大的三个指标，首先，在任何关系中都是巨大的危险信号（红线），同时也会引起大量的人际冲突和困难。这些就是与自恋及其在人们身上表现相关的三个巨大的危险信号。这些是缺乏界限，不为自己的行为承担责任。所以一个自恋者，他们总是把外部事件、人或者情绪归咎于
their own actions, which, oh my God, I can relate to. That was just like this person I used to date. And any time I'd be like, oh, you know, probably shouldn't have treated me like that. Probably shouldn't have said that. Didn't really appreciate that. They'd be like, oh, you know it's just because of this that's happened and it's because i've because i'm suffering it's because of my emotions like it has nothing to do with you has nothing to do with me not caring about you it has everything to do with external events and finally a big red flag and a big thing that narcissists often show it's just a general lack of empathy um yeah like i said like the lack of responsibility was a big big one for me that that i think i saw and this person that i used to
他们自己的行为，哦天哪，我对此感同身受。就像我以前约会过的那个人一样。每当我想要说，哦，你知道，你大概不应该那样对我的。大概不应该那样说。我真的不太欣赏那样。他们就会说，哦，你知道这只是因为发生了这个事，是因为我一直在遭受痛苦，是因为我的情绪，这跟你没关系，这跟我不在乎你也毫无关系，这完全是因为外部事件。最后，一个巨大的危险信号以及自恋者经常表现出的一个重大特征，就是普遍缺乏同理心。嗯，是的，就像我说的，不承担责任对我来说是一个非常非常大的问题，我想我在我曾经
day, you know, anytime they did something wrong, we're confronted with this, they could never see the hurt that that would cause and would constantly blame these external events, particularly like uni and stress and housing situation. So they just were unable to be held accountable for how they treated others. There was also always like an urgency to make things right so that they could redeem themselves as the good guy, rather than like actually taking real and honest responsibility for their actions. But even in those situations, you only really seemed aware of his own emotions in terms of like, he's upset me. It's not that he wants me to feel better. It's that he doesn't want to feel bad about it anymore. And I think that's a big common misconception
约会的这个人身上看到了这一点，你知道，每当他们做了错事，我们面对这一点时，他们永远看不到这会造成的伤害，并且会不断将这些外部事件归咎于此，尤其是像大学学业、压力和住房状况。因此，他们根本无法为自己如何对待他人承担责任。而且总是有一种紧迫感想要把事情做好，这样他们就能将自己赎回为好人，而不是真正诚实地对自己的行动承担真正的责任。但即使在那种情况下，你似乎也只能从他感到沮丧的角度意识到他自己的情绪。并不是他希望我感觉好点。而是他不想再为此感到难过了。我认为这是一个关于自恋的非常普遍的重大误解，
about narcissism, that they can't feel emotions. They can. They can feel emotions, but they can't see those same emotions in others. They can recognize them, but even that, maybe not as much as a normal person or someone who was an empath could. And although they can see emotions and others, they can never really comprehend that the intensity that someone is feeling an emotion might be the same intensity they would feel that emotion. So things like anger, sadness, guilt, grief,
即他们感觉不到情绪。他们能。他们能感觉到情绪，但他们在其他人身上看不到同样的情绪。他们能认出它们，但即使那样，也许也不如正常人或有同理心的人那样多。尽管他们能看到别人的情绪，但他们永远无法真正理解某人所感受到的情绪的强度，可能与他们自己感受这种情绪的强度相同。所以像愤怒、悲伤、内疚、悲痛这些事情，
they can feel all these things, but they're unable to connect the emotions they're feeling with the experiences of others. This is why they also seem to have really poor emotional regulation, you know, large up and down, falls in self-esteem and then return to this grandiose sense of self. Another big trait is an inability to appreciate how others see them and an obsession with outside perceptions and being liked and in people's focus,
他们能感受到所有这些事情，但他们无法将自己感受到的情绪与他人的经历联系起来。这也是为什么他们似乎也有很差的情绪调节能力，你知道，自尊心有很大的起伏，然后又回到这种夸大的自我感。另一个主要特征是无法欣赏别人是如何看待他们的，并且痴迷于外界的看法、被人喜欢以及成为人们关注的焦点，
you know, like calling yourself a big name, for example, like constantly feeling the need to be important starting new projects that you think will make others like you. So they often idealize others that represent perfection, which is kind of followed by devaluing that very person when they are perceived to have failed them. So, you know, you might have someone that a narcissist might have someone they really look up to. And their opinion just seems so, so important. And there's an obsession over whether they like them, trying to become closer to them.
你知道，比如给自己起个大名鼎鼎的名字，例如，不断觉得有必要变得重要，开始你认为会赢得别人喜欢的新项目。所以他们经常将代表完美的人理想化，当他们被认为让他们失望时，这种理想化就会紧接着变成对同一个人的贬低。所以，你知道，你可能会遇到这样的人，自恋者可能会有他们非常仰慕的人。而他们的意见看起来是如此、如此重要。并且他们痴迷于对方是否喜欢他们，试图拉近与对方的距离。
But then they're also highly dismissive of that person because if they can't live up to the expectations they feel that person might have for them, it's a lot easier to, you know, knock that person down in your own mind than address your own ego. Anyhow, well, all this paints a very flattering picture. I think it's fairly obvious how so many of these traits would make friendships and relationships with these kinds of people fairly difficult. I think it's hard to be emotionally attached to someone who is incapable of ever relating to how you feel. And clinically, as well as chronically, they just don't care.
但随后他们也会高度解雇和轻视那个人，因为如果那个人无法达到他们所感受到的那个人可能对他们的期望，那么在你的内心里把那个人贬低，要比处理你自己的自我价值感容易得多。无论如何，这一切描绘了一幅非常讨人喜欢的画面。我认为显而易见的是，为什么这么多这样的特质会使与这类人的友谊和关系变得相当困难。我认为很难对一个无法与你的感受产生共鸣的人产生情感上的依恋。无论是在临床上还是在日常生活中，他们就是不在乎。
You know, it's not even like they have any control over it. It's just like they have a pathological apathy, even to those that you would think that they would love. And they're just so focused on themselves that they cannot really see their partner as a separate person. They tend to only see their partner in terms of how they feel their needs or fail to fill their needs, another side of the coin. I think often from like doing some research and like personal experience and just talking to people who've had this experience, the dynamics often play out a lot more insidiously.
你知道，这甚至不像是他们对此有什么控制力。这就像他们有一种病态的冷漠，甚至对那些你认为他们会爱的人也是如此。他们太专注于自己，以至于无法真正将伴侣视为一个独立的人。他们往往只从伴侣是否满足他们的需求或未能满足他们的需求的角度来看待伴侣，这是硬币的另一面。我认为通常通过做一些研究、个人经历以及与有过这种经历的人交谈，这种动态往往会以更隐蔽的方式上演。
So you might talk about an issue and your partner relates it immediately to something that happened to them and your story kind of fades as theirs takeover. Or you know, you and your partner or your boyfriend or your girlfriend disagree and somehow you end up, you know, second guessing yourself as if kind of dissent will threaten their whole well-being. so you don't want to do that. You don't want to have to face what happens when you tell them they're wrong. And any needs you communicate that aren't in line with theirs may just be thrown back at you as a character floor of yourself or as something that's wrong with you. These are just like a few examples of what a relationship with a narcissist might look like. And I think really importantly, falling in love can put you off balance.
所以你可能会谈论一个问题，而你的伴侣会立刻将其与发生在他们身上的事情联系起来，你的故事随着他们的接管而逐渐淡出。或者你知道，你和你的伴侣、男朋友或女朋友意见不合，不知怎的，你最终开始质疑自己，就好像不同意见会威胁到他们的整体幸福感一样，所以你不想那样做。你不想去面对当你告诉他们他们错了时会发生什么。你所表达的任何不符合他们需求的需求，都可能会被反掷给你，作为你自身的性格缺陷或你身上不对劲的地方。这些只是与自恋者恋爱可能会是什么样子的几个例子。我认为非常重要的是，坠入爱河可能会让你失去平衡。
but standing in a love that is that you trust and standing in a love when you know you're cared about that firmly grounds you and an absolutely essential ingredient of any good relationship I think is like emotional safety like you need to feel safe to be your authentic self and to be happy but it's very difficult to be yourself and to feel connected to yourself when you have such an emotionally volatile partner which might be the case with the narcissistic. I think another really important thing, and I read this really interesting article that was talking about this, relationships with a person who has narcissistic traits can and survive. They are possible if, you know, you as the partner have good self-esteem, you have strong boundaries,
但置身于你信任的爱中，置身于你知道自己被关心的爱中，会让你坚定地脚踏实地。我认为任何良好关系中绝对必不可少的成分是情感安全——你需要感到安全才能做真实的自己并感到快乐，但当你有一个情感上如此不稳定的伴侣时，要保持自我并与自己保持联系是非常困难的，自恋者可能就是这种情况。我认为另一个非常重要的事情，我读过一篇非常有趣的文章在讨论这个，与具有自恋特质的人建立关系是可以并且能够存活下来的。如果作为伴侣的你拥有良好的自尊、坚定的界限，这其实是可能的，
resources in particular that are valued by the narcissist, patients and even tempered personality, and also a reason to stay with them throughout all these downfalls and faults. And I think over time this sort of self-esteem that you need to have, it will require positive and good and strong reinforcement from other parts of your life like work and friends in order to be maintained and to ensure that your relationship with that kind of energy-sucking individual can continue. And that reason to stay. I think people are attracted to different things in confidence, motivation, power, attention, all of which narcissistic partners, can provide and it can offer motivation to someone who might be with a narcissistic partner in the short term and the long term to stick around but of course it can be volatile and it's not like you can just tell that person to go to therapy because it's unlikely they'll believe that anything
特别是那些被自恋者看重的资源，耐心和温和的性格，以及在经历所有这些低谷和缺点时留下来陪他们的理由。我认为随着时间的推移，你需要拥有的这种自尊，将需要来自你生活中其他部分（如工作和朋友）的积极、良好和强有力的强化，以便维持下去，并确保你与那种消耗精力的个人的关系能够继续。以及留下来陪他们的理由。我认为人们会被自信、动力、权力、关注等不同的东西所吸引，自恋的伴侣都能提供所有这些，并且它可以为可能与自恋伴侣在一起的人提供短期和长期的坚持下去的动力，但当然它可能是不稳定的，而且你不能只是告诉那个人去看治疗，因为他们不太可能相信有什么
is wrong so it can become pretty one-sided or dare we say toxic although i'm not a big fan of that word And I think a really good hallmark that I kind of saw in my own relationship for realizing that things aren't going right, that the relationship is one-sided, that it isn't healthy, is that if you wouldn't feel comfortable telling your friends and family how someone treats you or the things that they say to you, you probably shouldn't be with them if their narcissistic traits are that pronounced. So if you wouldn't feel comfortable telling, you know, your best friend, oh, you know, I was really upset about this and he just said like, oh, he related it back to himself and, you know, how hard his life is, or told me I was overreacting or that the reason I was sad was incorrect. If you wouldn't feel comfortable telling your friend that your emotions or your needs were neglected, then it's probably not something you should tolerate. And that's what I found where I was like, oh, I don't feel.
问题，所以它可能会变得相当片面，或者我们敢说有毒，尽管我不是那个词的超级粉丝。我认为在我自己的关系中，我看到的一个很好的标志，用来意识到事情进展不顺利，关系是片面的、不健康的，那就是如果你觉得告诉你的朋友和家人别人是如何对待你的或者他们对你说的话让你感到不自在，如果他们的自恋特质如此明显，你大概就不应该和他们在一起。所以如果你觉得告诉你的好朋友，哦，你知道，我对此真的很沮丧，而他只是说，哦，他把这扯回到了他自己身上，以及他的生活有多艰难，或者告诉我我反应过度了，或者我难过的原因是不对的，让你感到不自在的话。如果你觉得告诉你的朋友你的情绪或需求被忽视了会感到不自在，那么这可能不是你应该容忍的事情。那就是我发现的时候，当时我想，哦，我不觉得
comfortable telling my friends the extent to which some of these things have been said to me or how I'm being treated because I know that they wouldn't like him anymore and I want them to like him so it kind of became this like almost like a bit of a like a bit of a play I don't know like a two like living two lives like the one where I was with this person who I loved but who had all these traits of like excessive need for attention a sense of self-entitlement just an excessive of need to be praised by others, to be liked by others. And then I had my own life where I was trying to just like do my own thing and be happy and healthy and myself.
自在去告诉我的朋友这些事情对我说出口的程度，或者我受到的对待，因为我知道他们会不再喜欢他，而我希望他们喜欢他，所以这有点变成了像是一场戏，我不知道，就像过着两种生活——一种是我和这个人在一起，我爱这个人，但他有所有这些特质，比如过度需要关注、自以为是的优越感、过度需要得到别人的称赞、得到别人的喜欢。然后我还有我自己的生活，我只是想做我自己的事，保持快乐、健康和自我。
I think this is a good time to kind of jump into the clinical underpinnings of narcissism before we kind of talk more about how to set boundaries with these types of people. So narcissism has been around as long as, you know, humanity has been around, really. And the term itself comes from the story of narcissists in Greek mythology, essentially, you haven't heard the story, but I'm pretty sure it's a common one. But I'll recap it. I bring some classics into this psychology podcast. So Narcissus is the story of a Greek hunter who is the son of a river god,
我认为现在是时候深入探讨自恋的临床基础了，在我们进一步讨论如何与这类人划定界限之前。所以自恋和人类存在的时间一样久远，真的。这个词本身源自希腊神话中纳西索斯（Narcissus）的故事，基本上，如果你没听过这个故事，但我确信这是一个很常见的传说。但我还是会重温一下。我把一些经典带入这个心理学播客中。所以纳西索斯的故事讲的是一个希腊猎人，他是河神塞菲索斯（Cephissus）和一个宁芙仙子的儿子。他非常漂亮，巴拉巴拉。他拒绝了一个非常美丽的宁芙仙子名叫回声（Echo）。而她在森林里走来走去，哀悼他。这就是“回声”这个词的由来，直到能听到她的声音只剩下回声。
Cephasis and a nymph. And he's very beautiful, blah, blah, blah. And he rejects this really beautiful nymph called Echo. And she walks around the forest, you know, in lamenting, mourning him. And that's where the word echo comes from, you know, until all that's heard of her voices is an echo. and this punishment for his rejection of her, the god of retribution and revenge, Nemesis, leads him to a pool or a pond where he is forced to see his reflection and Nemesis causes him to fall in love with this reflection. And although he doesn't really realize in the beginning
作为对她拒绝的惩罚，报应和复仇之神涅墨西斯（Nemesis）把他引到一个水池或池塘边，在那里他被迫看到自己的倒影，涅墨西斯使他爱上了这个倒影。虽然他一开始并没有真正意识到
that it is just him in the face of the water, when he comes to understands it, he falls into a despair that his love cannot materialize, that he could never, you know, be in love with another person as much as he loves himself and he commits suicide. So hopefully we see the links between modern day clinical narcissism and this kind of story of self-love and indulgence. But the formal diagnosis kind of began with Freud and different schools of psychology. They all kind of accept slightly different understandings of the pathology of this personality disorder and where it comes from, if treatment is possible and the details of what it really means. Firstly, let's clear this narcissism it is a disorder as we would as we would classify it like a disorder in
那只是水面上面部轮廓的自己，当他明白过来时，他陷入绝望，因为他的爱无法实现，他永远无法像爱自己那样去爱另一个人，于是他自杀了。所以希望我们能看到现代临床自恋与这种自爱和纵容的故事之间的联系。但正式的诊断始于弗洛伊德和不同的心理学流派。他们对这种人格障碍的病理学及其来源、治疗是否可能以及它真正意味着什么细节，都有着稍微不同的理解。首先，让我们澄清一下，自恋是一种障碍，正如我们所分类的那样——一种会导致功能受损的障碍，它是不正常的，它是异常的，它是一种人格障碍。而且我希望不言而喻的是，可诊断的自恋要复杂得多，而且往往比单纯的自私或虚荣更危险。所以我们已经讨论了具有自恋人格的一些特征或标准，我们讨论了那种夸大的自我重要感、对过度赞美的需求、特权感、在人际关系中剥削他人，等等。如果你想阅读它，你可以在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中读到。
terms of it causes impairment it's not normal it's abnormal it's a personality disorder and it kind of goes without saying I would hope that diagnosable narcissism is is far more complex and often more dangerous than just me as selfish or selfishness or vanity so we've already discussed some of the characteristics or criteria of having narcissistic personality we've discussed that grandiose sense of self-importance the need for excessive admiration, entitlement, being interpersonally exploited, the list goes on. If you want to read it, you can read it out in the DSM.
但自恋还有一个核心要素，必须存在才能确立障碍。所以任何人格障碍的基本特征都是自我和人际功能的损害。这就是为什么有些人认为，例如唐纳德·特朗普这样的人物不能被贴上自恋者的标签，尽管这看起来完全有可能。因为他似乎并没有过度受损。你知道，他成了总统。这并不表现出无法保住工作或缺乏方向感。
But there's another core element of narcissism that must be present for a disorder to be identified. So the essential features of any personality disorder are impairments in self and interpersonal functioning. This is why some people have argued that figures like Donald Trump, for example, can't be labeled narcissists, even though it seems quite possible. because he doesn't seem overly impaired. You know, he became president. That doesn't show an inability to hold down a job or a lack of direction.
有一些关键领域更有可能出现受损。例如，自我功能的受损，特别是在自我认同、自尊心的巨大波动和自我方向感方面。自恋者，被诊断为自恋者的人，可能无法设定现实的目标，或者无法将自己的目标与他人的认可区分开来，
And there are some key areas where impairment is more likely. For example, impairments in self-functioning, especially in terms of self-identity and huge fluctuations in self-esteem and self-direction. A narcissist, someone who is diagnosed as a narcissist, may be unable to set goals that are realistic or separate their goals. from the approval of others, and their personal standards are often unreasonably high in order to maintain the idea that they are exceptional, which can actually have the inverse effect of making them quite unimpressive because the fallout from when they can't meet
他们的个人标准往往高得不合理，以维持他们是非凡的这种想法，这实际上可能会产生相反的效果，让他们显得相当平庸，因为无法达到过高目标所带来的后果可能是极其戏剧性的。另一个普遍受损的领域是人际功能，特别是在亲密关系方面。我们已经讨论过了，自恋者和正常人之间的关系在很大程度上可能是肤浅的，因为它们的存在是为了服务于他们的自尊。因此，一个具有自恋倾向的人可能会在无法维持个人关系或长期友谊方面经历功能失调。受损的其他领域还包括他们过度试图吸引和集中
excessive goals can be so dramatic. The other area where impairment is common is in interpersonal functioning, specifically in terms of intimacy. We've already talked about this, but relationships between a narcissist and a regular person can be largely superficial because they exist to serve their self-esteem. Therefore, like a person who is narcissistic might experience dysfunction in their inability to maintain a personal relationship or a long-term friendship. And other areas of impairment also relate to their excessive attempts to attract and focus
注意力在自己身上，这可能会导致功能失调，例如在教室里、同龄人之间或工作中。如果我们有一个总是需要把注意力集中在自己身上的同事，那他不会是一个非常高效的同事，他可能会惹恼很多人，显得有点拍马屁。这可能意味着，归根结底，他们其实更难取得进展，或者更难在职场中受到喜爱和接纳。有一个小细则我觉得非常有趣。
attention on themselves, and this can cause dysfunction, for example, in a classroom, amongst peers or at work. We've got someone who always needs the attention on them. They're not going to be a very productive co-worker. they're probably going to piss a lot of people off, come off as being a bit of a brown noser. And that can mean that it's harder for them to get ahead actually at the end of the day, or it's harder for them to be liked and to be accepted in a workplace. There is one small caveat that I found really interesting.
所以也许我应该解释一下。我想我差不多已经解释过了。但本质上，如果你是一名心理学家或精神病学家，有人来找你，首先，他们极不可能给自己贴上自恋者的标签，或者因为他们可能由于自恋而表现出的明确特质而寻求帮助。一个人来找你说“我是个自恋者，我认为这是一个问题”的可能性极小。他们可能是因为某种其他形式的功能受损而来的，
So maybe I should explain this. I think I've kind of already done it. But essentially, if you're a psychologist or a psychiatrist, and you have someone come in, firstly, it's highly unlikely that they're going to label themselves as a narcissist or seek help because of their express traits that may be due to narcissism. It's very unlikely that someone is going to come in and say, I'm a narcissist and I think this is a problem. They're probably going to be coming in for some other form of impairment,
也许是家庭治疗，也许是他们被工作场所或伴侣推荐来的。但你与这个人交谈，了解他们的性格，如果你怀疑他们可能是自恋的，你就会应用《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中的这些标准。根据具体的障碍，你在应用它，一个人需要满足一定数量的设定标准才能被诊断。对于自恋，一个人只需要表现出被确定的特征的 55%
maybe family therapy, maybe they've been recommended by their workplace or by their partner. But you talk to this person, you get a sense of their character, and if you have a suspicion that they may be narcissistic, you apply this criteria that is in the DSM. And depending on the disorder, you're applying it, a person needs to meet a certain number of set criteria to be diagnosed. For narcissism, a person needs to exhibit only 55% of the identified characteristics
就可以被诊断为人格障碍。这个比例真的很低。对于抑郁症或大多数常见的焦虑症，你必须满足，我想，可能是七分之五的标准，并且其中两个标准是不可选的。所以你必须在过去的 3 到 12 个月里拥有这些才能被诊断。但《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中关于自恋的一小部分指出，人格功能的损害和个人人格特质的表现，不能更好地被理解为是个体社会文化环境的规范。
to be diagnosed with the personality disorder. And this is really low. For depression or most common anxiety disorders, you have to meet, I think, like, it might be like five out of seven criteria and two of those criteria aren't optional. So you have to have had those in the past three, to 12 months to be diagnosed. But there is one small part of the DSM when it comes to narcissism which says the impairments in personality functioning and the individual's personality trade expression are not better understood as normative for the individual socio-cultural environment.
这真的很有趣，我认为也非常关键，因为在某些文化中，过度的自信或缺乏同理心以及人际剥削受到垂涎或赞美，一个人在技术上可能不被视为自恋者。例如，在资本主义和竞争激烈的社会中，可以提出这样一个论点，即自恋者实际上是变少了而不是变多了，因为这些特质可以在社会文化环境中得到解释并被接受。关于自恋的另一件事是，你永远无法自我诊断。所以如果你担心自己可能是个自恋者，你大概就不是。自恋者通常缺乏那种善解人意的自我反思，而这种反思可能会让他们怀疑自己是否有人格障碍。
This is really interesting and I think really crucial because in some cultures where excessive self-confidence or lack of empathy and interpersonal exploitation are coveted or celebrated, a person may not technically be deemed a narcissist. For example, like in capitalist and competitive societies, an argument could be made that there are actually fewer rather than more narcissists because the traits can be explained and are accepted within the socio-cultural environment. Another thing about narcissism is that you can never self-diagnose. So if you're worried that you might be a narcissist, you're probably not one. Narcissists generally lack the kind of empathetic self-reflection that might make them wonder if they have a personality disorder.
这就是为什么自恋很少得到治疗，为什么很难、甚至可能无法真正量化有多少人患有这种障碍的原因。所以让我们来谈谈治疗，因为如果它被认为是一种障碍以及对我们关系和功能的破坏，我们就会希望心理学家某种形式的治疗计划。简单来说，没有，他们没有。这是一种如此难以捉摸的障碍，以至于没有药物，也没有治疗自恋的常见认知行为疗法（CBT）或疗法形式。他们使用的最常见的方法之一是心理疗法。
And this is why narcissism is so seldom treated and why it's really hard, or maybe even possible, to truly quantify how many people have the disorder. So let's kind of talk about treatment, because if it is considered a disorder and a disruption to our relationships and our functioning, we would hope that psychologists have some form of treatment plan. Just to put it simply, no, they don't. It's such an elusive disorder that there is no medication, no common form of CBT or therapy to treat narcissism. One of the most common measures that they do use is psychotherapy.
所以心理疗法在心理学中是一种相当普遍的技术，如果你去看心理咨询师，它基本上是通过谈论你的问题，你可以分析你的行为在无意识中是如何产生的。因此，如果你是一个自恋者，心理疗法可以帮助你学会更好地与他人建立联系，从而使你的关系更具亲密感和回报感。它还可以帮助你了解情绪的起因，以及是什么驱使你去竞争、去不信任他人，或者可能拥有那种奇怪的自尊心过山车。改变的领域旨在帮助你承担责任，并学会接受和维持与同事等人的关系和合作，或者接受你实际的能力和潜力，
So psychotherapy is a pretty, I would say, common technique in psychology or if you go and see a counselor, it's basically like by talking about your problems, you can kind of analyze where your behaviors come from, unconsciously. So psychotherapy can help you, if you are a narcissist, kind of learn to relate better with others so your relationships are more intimate and rewarding. And it also helps you understand the causes of your emotions and what drives you to compete, to distrust others and perhaps to have that weird roller coaster of self-esteem. And areas of change are directed at kind of helping you accept responsibility and learning to accept and maintain relationships and collaboration with people like your co-workers or accept your actual competence and potential so
以便你能容忍批评或失败。它还旨在提高自恋者调节情绪和感受的能力，因为这些情绪可能会非常不稳定，并理解和容忍与自尊相关的问题的影响。所以这是心理疗法和治疗自恋者的基础，但它非常无效，且流失率很高。因此，不仅很难让一个自恋者去看治疗，而且很难让他们坚持下去。有时它甚至会产生适得其反的效果，因为我们在自恋者身上看到的那些我们可能鄙视的特质，实际上可以使人们在商业、职业生涯以及许多领域的谈判中取得巨大的成功。所以这仍然
that you can tolerate criticisms or failures. It also aims to kind of increase a narcissist's ability to regulate their emotions and their feelings because they can be so volatile and to also understand and tolerate the impact of issues related to their self-esteem. So this is kind of the basis of psychotherapy and treating a narcissist but it's highly ineffective and has really high dropout rates. So not only is it hard to get someone who is a narcissist to go to therapy, but it's hard to get them to stick around. Sometimes it can even work against their best interest because so many of those traits that we might despise that we see in a narcissist can actually make people really successful in business and in their careers and negotiating in a lot of areas, really. So it's still
是一个非常丰富的研究领域，如果你愿意和一群自恋者呆在一起并试图教他们同理心的话，这也是为什么自恋者经常被用于许多关于同理心是天生还是后天培养的，以及如何在人们（特别是儿童）身上建立同理心的研究中。这算是一个很好的过渡，进入关于自恋的天性与养育之争，这在大多数人格障碍中都是一个巨大的话题，但对这一种尤其如此。所以每个人都会问的问题是，一个人是如何成为自恋者的？因为我们有点想避免这些人的出现。这是精神病学界激烈争论的一个问题。
a really rich area of research if you feel like hanging around a bunch of narcissists and trying to teach them empathy, which is why narcissists are often used in a lot of studies around whether empathy is nature and nurture and how it can be built in people, specifically children. That's kind of a good segue into the nature v. nurture debate around narcissism, which is such a huge topic when it comes to most personality disorders, but this one in particular. So the question everyone kind of asks is, how does a person become a narcissist? Because we kind of want to avoid these people from showing up. And it's a hotly disputed issue in the world of psychiatry.
这里有大量的理论，没有千篇一律的答案。但这位专门研究该领域的非常著名的心理学家的观点是，这大概有 25% 是体质上的，或者由于你的基因或生物学基础，而 75% 是外部因素。因此，自恋者不一定来自一个破裂的、功能失调的家庭，但自恋的产生可能是因为父母或看护人无法提供情感关注，或者也可能是相反的情况。父母提供了太多的关注，而孩子从未学会挫折耐受力。这真的取决于具体情况，相同的情况可能会导致
And there's a wealth of theories, no kind of one-size-fits-all answer. But the view of this very famous psychologist whose speciality is in this area is that it's probably about 25% constitutional or due to your genetics or biological underpinnings, and 75% is external. So a narcissist doesn't necessarily come from a domestic. dysfunctional family, but narcissism can occur because a parent or caretaker wasn't able to provide emotional attention or it could be the flip side. A parent provided too much attention and the child never learned frustration tolerance. It really depends and the same situation can result in
不同的人产生不同的结果。因此，许多研究人员发现的促成环境因素可能包括童年虐待或忽视、父母过度溺爱、来自父母的不切实际的期望、性乱交，但这往往伴随着自恋而不是导致自恋，以及大量的文化影响。所以到目前为止，它似乎确实非常受环境影响，但一些神经模型表明这是一种遗传性疾病，并探讨了由育儿风格激活的自私基因的想法。因此，它似乎更多是遗传和环境的结合。所以如果你认识一个自恋者，尽管他们的行为可能会惹恼你并伤害你，但我们还是有必要
different outcomes for different people. So contributing environmental factors that a lot of researchers kind of found may include childhood abuse or neglect, excessive parental pampering, unrealistic, expectations from parents, sexual promiscuity, but this often accompanies narcissism rather than causing it, and a lot of cultural influences. So so far it kind of does seem to be very environmental, but some neural models have suggested that it is an inherited condition and have this kind of explored the idea of a selfish gene that is activated by parenting style. So it appears to be more of a combination of genetics and environment. So if you know a narcissist, assist as much as their behavior may annoy you and hurt you, it's kind of necessary that we
认识到这其实并不是他们的错。他们通常有一种生物学上的倾向，这是他们出生时就存在的某种东西，然后被触发，从而创造了这种人格、这种身份，它是病理性的、慢性的，他们对此真的无能为力。我知道这种说法听起来有点离奇，考虑到我对那些有这些特质的人进行了多少批判，以及他们在关系中有多糟糕，等等等等，但这是我们在观察人格障碍时经常不得不考虑的令人面对的现实之一，那就是这在多大程度上真的是那个人的错？这是他们人格的一部分，是的，但他们在决定自己这种最终结果方面的控制权是如此之小，
recognize that it's not really their fault. They often have like a bio, it's often something biologically that was there when they were born, that was then triggered, that's created this personality, this identity, and it's pathological, it's chronic, they can't really do anything about it. And I know this account sounds kind of bizarre, considering how much I've kind of shitted on people who have these traits and how terrible they are in relationships, blah, blah, blah, blah, but it's one of these confronting things that we often have to consider when looking at personality disorders in particular is how much is it really that person's fault? It's part of their personality, yes, but they also have so little control in determining this outcome for themselves
而归根结底它确实给他们带来了机能损害。它会损害他们的关系。拥有这些特质、成为自恋者、踩在别人头上、没有同理心、具有剥削性、需要大量关注以及有特权意识，对他们来说其实并不是一种选择。但问题是，我们究竟能把这种逻辑延伸到多远？因为那样我们就可以把这种“这不是你的错”的说法，延伸到一个人人格和缺陷的任何元素上。无论如何，稍微偏离一下主题。我觉得思考这一点挺有意思的，
and it does at the end of the day cause them impairment. It can hurt their relationships. It's not really a choice for them to have these traits, to be a narcissist, to step on people, to not have empathy, to be exploitative and need a lot of attention and self-entitled. But the question is, how far can we really stretch that logic? Because then we can kind of extend this, it's not your fault claim, to any element of someone's personality and their flaws. Anyways, a little bit of a segue. I think it's just kind of interesting to think about that,
归根结底，这确实会给他们造成功能损害。这会伤害他们的人际关系。对他们来说，拥有这些特质、成为一个自恋狂、践踏他人、缺乏同理心、具有剥削性、需要大量关注以及自我感觉良好，其实并不是一种选择。但问题是，我们究竟能把这种逻辑推演到多远？因为这样一来，我们就可以把这种“这不是你的错”的说法，推广到一个人性格和缺点的任何方面。不管怎样，这算是个小插曲。我觉得思考这些挺有意思的，
think about where we place personality disorders in terms of our conceptions of right and wrong, whether someone who is a narcissist or a psychopath or a sociopath can be seen as bad or worse than others when really they didn't have any say in the kind of person they turned out to be the way that we kind of didn't have any say in the way we turned out to be and perhaps our nicer temperaments or those that are more agreeable let's move away from the science for a bit and kind of conclude this episode by talking about how to cut ties with a narcissist, which can be especially hard considering how charismatic and powerful they can feel and the emotional vortex they create around them. So I read up on some tips about this if you are maybe seeking advice, and I'm guessing
想想我们如何根据对对与错的观念来定位人格障碍，一个自恋狂、精神病态者或反社会人格者是否可以被视为比其他人更坏或更糟糕，而实际上他们对于自己最终变成什么样的人根本没有任何发言权，就像我们对于自己最终变成什么样的人也没有任何发言权一样，也许我们更善良的气质或那些更随和的人，让我们暂时抛开科学，通过讨论如何与自恋者断绝关系来为这一集做个总结，考虑到他们能给人带来多么有魅力和强大的感觉以及他们在周围制造的情绪漩涡，这可能尤其困难。因此，如果你可能在寻求建议，我读到了一些关于这方面的技巧，而且我猜
if you have listened this far, you probably have some personal attachment or have identified someone in your life who may be narcissistic and probably want to know how to deal with it because, oh my god it can be fucking exhausting this might be extreme but it might be necessary and it's a strategy that I saw all over the place that is recommended and it's called the no contact rule which you could probably apply to a lot of people
如果你听到了这里，你可能与某些人有私人联系，或者在生活中认出了某个可能是自恋者的人，并且可能想知道如何应对，因为，天哪，这简直太累人了，这可能是极端的，但可能是必要的，这是我到处都看到的一种被推荐的策略，被称为“不联系原则”，你大概可以把它应用到很多人身上
who you might deem as a bad view or negative in your life so the no contact rule is a method used in order to cut ties with a narcissist a sociopath or some other form of emotional manipulator and as the name suggests, it's all about stopping every kind of communication with that person and cutting all ties with them so that you are unable to interact with them and they can't interact with you.
你可能会认为在你的生活中是不好的看法或消极的人，所以“不联系原则”是一种与自恋者、反社会者或其他形式的情感操纵者断绝关系的方法，顾名思义，它就是停止与该人的所有沟通，切断与他们的所有联系，这样你就无法与他们互动，他们也无法与你在互动。
For instance, not facing the narcissist under any circumstances. So whether you're alone in public or surrounded by friends, not calling or texting or communicating with them, blocking their phone number, blocking their Instagram, blocking their Facebook from any social media account. in fact, maybe even deactivating your own account as well if you're worried that you might not be able to resist talking to them when you definitely need a bit of a break. And if it's a family member, this may be harder. We can't really expect that they will respect your decision because, well, as we kind of talked about, they're incapable of respecting boundaries or understanding
例如，在任何情况下都不与自恋者见面。因此，无论你是独自在公共场所还是被朋友包围，都不要打电话、发短信或与他们交流，屏蔽他们的电话号码，屏蔽他们的Instagram，从任何社交媒体账号上屏蔽他们的Facebook。事实上，如果你担心自己可能无法抗拒与他们交谈的冲动而你确实需要休息一下，甚至可以考虑停用你自己的账号。如果这是一个家庭成员，这可能会更难。我们不能指望他们会尊重你的决定，因为，嗯，正如我们所讨论的，他们没有能力尊重界限或理解
emotional decisions. But I do think it's essential to stay firm and don't give in, if you believe that nothing has changed, which it unlikely has, because it is a chronic condition. This doesn't just go away. This is who this person is. And I think surrounding yourself with like a good support network, that's advice for anything really. And writing a list of why you've made the decision and why you want to stick with it. And I think the opinion I always have when making these kind of hard decisions, having these hard talks and making the decision to cut someone off or end things with someone is you'll be so much happier you've made the decision now rather than in three months because it's three more months of healing time for you. Anyhow, a bit of a weird episode,
情感上的决定。但我确实认为，保持坚定、不妥协是至关重要的，如果你相信一切都没有改变（实际上也不太可能改变），因为这是一种慢性疾病。这不会就此消失。这个人就是这样。而且我认为，身边有良好的支持网络，这其实是对任何事情的建议。并写一份清单，列出你为什么做出这个决定以及你为什么想坚持下去。而且我认为我每次做出这种艰难决定、进行这些艰难谈话并做出与某人断绝关系或结束关系的决定时，都有这样的想法：你会为自己现在就做出决定而感到高兴，而不是在三个月后，因为这对你来说又是三个月的治愈时间。不管怎样，这一集有点奇怪，
a bit of an emotional episode. A lot of baggage was unpacked and put away. I honestly, I'm like getting the feeling. I do just feel like this podcast is like a personal therapist or like source of catharsis for me. So much of my like personal life tends to filter in and maybe you've like noticed that in my intros. You know, what really determines these episodes is what I'm going through in my personal life rather and things I'm interested in this I think as well um not so much like the things I think are like that the most relevant like I think yeah narcissism is interesting but there aren't that many narcissists you might know one but it's not as common as like a breakup or feeling sad or jealousy or things like that but yeah just a really interesting topic I think to discuss and
有点情绪化的一集。很多包袱被打开又收拾好。老实说，我有一种感觉。我真的觉得这个podcast就像是我的私人治疗师或者是情绪宣泄的源泉。我的很多私生活往往会渗透进来，也许你在我的开场白中注意到了这一点。你知道，真正决定这些内容的其实是我在私生活中正在经历的事情，以及我感兴趣的事物，我认为这也一样，并不是说我觉得最相关的事情，比如我认为自恋很有趣，但自恋者并没有那么多，你可能认识一个，但它不像分手、感到悲伤或嫉妒那样常见，但无论如何，我认为这是一个非常有趣的话题，值得讨论，并且
I've mentioned it's just such a rich area of research we really don't know much about this disorder it's so elusive. It's so hard to find people to study. It's so hard to get people to commit to long-term therapy and to see whether after a certain point there is like a cure or like a treatment for narcissism, whether it's like entirely bad, um, how to like have a relationship with someone who's a narcissist because, you know, people do. It's not like the whole world of single people. It's just people who are narcissistic. Like many of, like, many of them, them will have relationships and they might even be functional. So how do we kind of compute that with our idea that they're like terrible and there are all these traits that we really dislike in
正如我所提到的，这是一个如此丰富的研究领域，我们对这种障碍真的知之甚少，它是如此难以捉摸。很难找到研究对象。很难让人承诺进行长期治疗，去看看在某个时间点之后是否存在某种针对自恋的治愈方法或治疗方法，它是否完全是坏的，嗯，如何与一个自恋者保持关系，因为，你知道，人们确实会这样做。这并不意味着单身的世界里全都是自恋者。只是有些人有自恋倾向。就像他们中的许多人一样，他们会谈恋爱，甚至可能运转正常。那么，我们如何将这一点与我们的观念调和起来呢？我们认为他们很糟糕，并且他们身上有很多我们非常讨厌的特质
others. So anyhow, a nice little conclusion to this episode. I hope you enjoyed it. I hope at least it was interesting that you learned something, a new fact for the week. And yeah, thanks for listening all the way through if you have, if you really liked this episode, make sure you to subscribe on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Google, wherever you're listening right. now and follow us on Instagram. It's called 20 Psychology Podcast. You can see the awful Instagram reels I've been making as of recent. And yeah, have a great week. Hope you enjoyed this episode that you learned something. And we will see you next time for some more juicy discussions. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
其他人。所以无论如何，这是对这一集的一个美好的小结。希望你喜欢。希望它至少很有趣，让你学到了一周的新知识。如果你一路听了下来，非常感谢你的收听，如果你真的很喜欢这一集，请确保在Apple Podcasts、Spotify、Google或你正在收听的任何地方订阅，并在Instagram上关注我们。账号是20 Psychology Podcast。你可以看到我最近制作的那些糟糕的Instagram短视频。好了，祝你度过愉快的一周。希望你喜欢这一集并且学到了东西。我们下次再见，进行更多精彩的讨论。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和韧性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和来说是个重要时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year.
84对我很重要。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈80年代。那是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
我认为没有比这更重要的一年对于黑人而言。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方真的都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHard radio应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个IHart播客。Guaranteed Human。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。